On Nov 4th 2019, former boy band member and
current fashion icon, Harry Styles, posted
an image to twitter.
Within 24 hours it racked up over half a million
likes.
It was the cover to his long awaited sophomore
album, and fans dissected every last detail.
From the pink and blue color palette,
which was used for the studio backdrop, his
custom Gucci outfit, and was even painted
on his fingernails.
To this disembodied hand in the corner, which
belongs to Tim Walker, the photographer.
And finally, the scandalous release date - Friday
December 13th.
His ex-girlfriend, Taylor Swift’s, birthday.
But zoom out to the whole image, and you’ll
see something that extends far beyond the
world of Harry Styles fandom.
This circular photograph is the latest in
a long line of album covers that have that
same warped composition.
This is the story of music’s obsession with
the fisheye lens.
In 1906 renowned physicist Robert W. Wood
was in his lab at Johns Hopkins University
with a bucket full of water, a pinhole camera,
mirrored glass, and a lot of light.
He wanted to see if he could create an image
of the world from the perspective of a fish.
Whose view from underwater compresses the
entire horizon.
This experiment might seem unusual, but Woods
was a professor of optical physics and he
dedicated his career to inventing unconventional
tools to study light.
From developing this disk whose microscopic
components helped determine the age of stars,
to inventing this toy which, according to
the patent, “created grotesque images of
people’s faces” through a series of perfectly
placed mirrors.
I first heard of him as being sort of an offbeat
kind of guy.
He often had a deep insight into things and
kind of a quirky way.
That’s John Beaver, a photographer who is
also a Professor of Physics and Astronomy.
That basic diagram of the rays coming at different
angles, I teach that all the time, it’s
in every beginning physics book.
But the idea of making a camera out of that,
I had never heard that Robert Wood had done
that.
In this paper, Wood detailed what he wanted
to see:
“the circular picture would contain everything
embraced within an angle of 180 degress in
every direction, i.e. a complete hemisphere.”
And luckily, he left us with a set of instructions.
Diameter of the paper, what’s that?
Open only in photography darkroom.
I feel like I’m about to murder somebody.
Let’s go get some water.
Anchors away.
Let’s get another one of those clamps.
In case of contact flash skin or eyes with
water for at least 15 minutes.
That’s fine.
Oh no it’s not because it has to be under
the pinhole.
I honestly have no idea how the hell he did
this.
I think there's an easy way for you to do it now that he couldn't have done.
You can just put a waterproof
GoPro in the bottom of the bucket.
God dammit.
Can we just cut to the pictures?
This is a picture he took from under a bridge.
This is a line up of men.
And this is what a fish might see if all those
men were looking down at it from above the
surface of a pond.
Soon, researchers and scientists built on
Wood’s idea.
From 1915 through the 1930s, it was the fields
of meteorology and astronomy that drove the
development of a camera lens that could capture
that coveted fisheye perspective.
And on the eve of World War II, German inventors
filed a patent for a lens which they then
shared with the Japanese company Nikon.
The lens used the same principles as Woods’
water experiment.
You can see it right in his diagram with the bucket.
As the light rays come in at a steep angle,
they come out at a less steep angle.
And so those light rays that are coming from
huge angles are compressed onto the picture.
In 1957 Nikon produced their first special
order fish-eye camera, factoring in inflation,
it was a $27,000 piece of gear.
Though they were still primarily used for
scientific research, a few caught the attention
of magazine and newspaper photographers.
This 1957 issue of Life Magazine, shows a
fisheye view of a senate hearing.
A few months later that same camera photographed
a pole vaulter mid jump.
And in 1962, Sixty years after Robert Woods’
original experiments, Nikon’s first
consumer grade fish-eye lens hit the market.
And it became a pop culture phenomenon.
It captured baseball stadiums
Shark cages
Political conventions
The Apollo trainings
And protests.
It was and always has been a handy tool to
capture tight quarters.
as well as huge spaces.
But perhaps its greatest strength was making
rock stars appear larger than life.
When the Beatles kicked off the British Invasion
in the mid 60s.
The fish eye lens was uniquely suited to document
the insanity.
Here they are at a Miami press conference.
And during a TV performance.
The len’s warped perspective reflected the
trippiness of the psychedelic era.
Including the Woodstock music festival.
This is jazz musician, Sam Rivers’, 1965
album Fuchsia Swing Song and it’s one of
the earliest fisheye album covers.
A few months later The Byrds Released Mr Tambourine
Man.
Over the next few years the fisheye album
art format cemented itself in music.
The most common format was this:
A giant circular fisheye lens portrait of
the artist or band.
with typography above and below it.
In more illustrated approaches, the font wraps
fully around the image
And some exclude the artist altogether, opting
to show an interesting scene or landscape.
Oh, I just thought of a fish eye album cover.
Do you know Hergest Ridge by Mike Oldfield?
No, but I’m going to look it up.
Wow that’s cool.
The fisheye lens was a go-to piece of gear
for music photographers and filmmakers by
the end of the 1970s.
It was there for concerts, television performances,
and photoshoots.
So by the time MTV launched in 1981, it was
inevitable that the super wide angle lens
would play a huge role in music videos.
It could get super close to a performer while
still capturing the space around them.
This is the music video for the Beastie Boys
track “Shake your Rump”
It was shot with at least three cameras equipped
with a fisheye lens.
Fisheye worked for every genre, from 60s hippies
to alt rock to hip hop.
But hip-hop had a sense of humor, and it was
in your face.
Which helped turn it into one of the genre’s
signature looks.
And in the 90s that's thanks to director Hype Williams.
—
From 1991 to 1999 he directed dozens of music video for top artists.
And many of those prominently featured a fisheye perspective.
Busta Rhymes,
TLC,
and of course, Missy Elliot.
The list goes on and on.
And let's not forget those album covers.
The Fisheye lens is, no doubt, a novelty.
When you see a photo taken with it, your eye
will likely first focus on the highly distorted
style of the image, and then register what’s
in it.
But that undersells how timeless and useful
of a tool it actually is.
One generation sees it as a psychedelic photography
trope.
Another a 1990s hip-hop throwback.
If you’re an astronomer, it helps you track
clouds moving across the atmosphere
and the terrain on the surface of Mars.
And if you’re as curious as Robert Woods,
it’ll let you see the world from the point
of view of
a fish.